[Music]
black against xentos
for c all right so we're going to play
acaro
again in this speedrun i play solid with
black and very aggressive with white
that's the sort of
uh spiel so we play mostly kyokon and
alakin with black although i'll
branch out a little bit once we hit 1400
and bishop f5 as we played yesterday
advanced car
thanks lana i appreciate you helping uh
enforce that
okay um so what do we do now
what do we do now um
yeah i do demon that's what i play in my
own games but this is more classical car
oh yeah so we play e6
we control more of the center and we
play c5
uh when possible bishop g5 is a move
that looks good
but actually isn't that great um
because it's it's sort of like shooting
into thin air right okay the bishop
looks
good here it's with tempo but it just it
just doesn't produce the
the kind of effect that we wanted us sky
bobbles points out
we have a beautiful spot for the queen
on b6 attacking the pawn and guess what
once we play c5
that queen is going to be perfectly
positioned to put pressure
on this d4 pawn and the bishop is just
going to look like the guy who goes stag
to prom
nothing wrong with that um but
you know you might just have to shuffle
back to c1 and
you know stay where the food is at all
right
okay
b3 i totally don't speak from c okay so
b3 uh doesn't change our strategy we go
c5 and we put pressure on this on the
pawn that's the
main idea of the advanced car for black
stay where the kebabs are exactly
yeah b3 is more is weakening right b3
weakens more squares here c3 is weak
so his position starts to slowly crumble
already
knight c3 all right so do we want to
take on d4 is the key question
and this is a little complicated the
other move is just to go knight c6 and
put the pressure on d4
and there is a specific reason that i
don't like
knight c6 can anybody spot why that is
and it has to do hint wink wink with the
snipe being on c3
it's threatening to go somewhere knight
a4 yeah knight a4
and attacking the pawn and attacking the
queen and as i'll show after the game
that can be a very unpleasant idea in
the karo khan
and in the french by the way when the
queen is on b6 it's annoying because he
he'll be able to root out the bishop on
f8 which and i want to keep this bishop
in fact this is the bishop
that can exploit the spin so here would
be a good spot to take on d4
particularly because he's gotten b3 so
what move should we play now
so cd is correct yes
this is a very juicy piece ladies and
gentlemen
we don't need to drop the bishop back
active play bishop b4 attack knight
with check yeah
and he's in some trouble here already
okay well knight c6 wouldn't have been
as effective because he can then take
the bishop and break up my pawn chain
uh maybe after this game i'll give a
short take um
before i end but uh mostly i'll talk
about it more tonight
uh and i'll be back to play blitz
tonight
okay but should be five so doesn't
does it impact what we do well we don't
want to move our we actually might want
to move our king
but let's not reinvent the wheel let's
just go knight c6
covering the check and developing our
knight i think you move the horse for
the prime
yeah this is very unpleasant you can see
how much this knight impacts
how difficult it is to play white's
position
okay queen f3 and he's just not able to
sustain he he sees that the knight is
saying but he forgets about the other
night
just queen takes d4 and it's over in
fact we might end up winning a second
piece here
thank you hot mom thank you hot mom
lover for
gifting to nf86
fab's music producer that's absolutely
not true
and um
all right queen takes a one and it's
over
in fact knight c one we take well this
was pretty simple this was a pretty easy
game
hey bruja good to see you and
bishop g5 like i said is not great the
best move here is bishop e2
the best move here is bishop e2 and then
castles very low key
but you keep keep things centered and
queen b6 is no longer as dangerous grand
gnz
with a five gifted damn girl thank you
for the five
much appreciated okay
so queen b6 yeah
c b3 c5 knight c3 cd i mean so again
if we go knight c6 here then knight a4
comes now it might not seem like a big
deal okay he's attacking our queen we
can move
aside with check but it is a big deal
now he drops the bishop to d2 attacks
the queen again
can't really cover with the knight
because of the pin
and you might say wait wait we take on
c2 that's a fork but then queen takes c2
oh and this is beautiful look at this
queen takes c2 right
if we take the queen
if we take the queen the bishop takes a5
and
i my bae and white is up a piece but
black can say wait a second
i'm more clever than you are i can play
queen takes a four
and we're even again but what can white
do here
this is amazing queen takes queen takes
bishop
another desperado sack and finally white
wins the
white wins the game because white's up a
piece black has no more things to
capture
that's amazing i love these desperado uh
situations where the queens just take a
bunch of pieces
that is a very funny line but it's very
thematic and very instructive you just
see how the desperado works
your queen's hanging let me give it up
for something at the very least yeah
black and play queen takes
d4 i guess but it's only a bun
all right yeah so that's the reason why
uh this is annoying if we move the queen
back then of course you can take the
pawn and i wasn't too hot about this
thank you and unlock for the prime
uh and so c takes d4 bishop before this
is extremely unpleasant for white i
think he
he can stay alive if he plays
yeah this is it's very hard to just keep
his pieces alive i think in this
position he should have played
i don't even know queen d2 i guess but
then we can play something like queen a5
now of course this is very bad for white
uh but something like this i i suppose
would have kept
chances alive of some sort all right
okay uh so that's a good nice and short
gaming okay he blundered all of his
pieces here but
it's it's easy to do that when your
position's sort of coming apart at the
seams
we're gonna play b3 we're gonna play one
b3
which you guys have seen me play a
million times it's actually one of my
main moves
actually proffer and it's the
queen side bishop skincare also known as
the nimzo larsen
opening now
there is very little that needs to be
said about this move because its idea is
obvious you're fianchettoing the bishop
those of you who are saying lame
trust me we're going to have some fun
this game um
and it is a hyper modern opening we're
not controlling any part of the center
we're doing it with our pieces instead
and the way that this is traditionally
played
the way that this is traditionally
played uh is in the
most direct spirit of hyper modern
openings where
all of your pressure occurs not
uh you're not building up your own
center you are purely attacking your
opponent's center
so what we do here and this is the old
main line recently people have started
going knight f3
the old main main line display e3
all right we're controlling a little bit
of the center but the
the basic idea of this is to open up
this bishop
now where should this bishop go based on
what i just
told you about the
idea behind this opening
bishop b5 of course in order to attack
tonight we're already threatening to win
a pawn
we're threatening to capture the knight
and capture the pawn
and it may not seem problematic for
black to defend it it's not black can go
d6
black can even go bishop d6 that's one
of the main moves
and black can go queen e7 but all of
those moves have pretty big drawbacks
queen e7 has the serious drawback that
is much harder now to develop this
bishop
okay
the obvious continuation is knight f3
and there's nothing wrong with that move
uh it puts more pressure on the pawn
but what is the drawback of playing
knight f3 what can black do in response
that you know may seem that actually is
a little bit annoying
they will push the pawn to e4 and attack
our knight again
and isn't the whole point to leave this
pawn on the operating table here on e5
so what do we do about this
well we don't want to develop the
knights f3 instead we want to develop it
to e2 but the point of this move isn't
only to make sure that e4 doesn't come
with tempo there's a secondary plan that
we are preparing
now we have to take the knight and you
might look at this and say
wait a second wasn't the whole point of
this move to increase our pressure of
this pawn and now
well this pawn isn't being attacked so
aren't we
you know doesn't our play kind of not
make logical sense
that's not entirely true we actually
still can
attack this pawn on e5 and put very
significant pressure on it
um in fact i will tell you that black is
already in trouble
i know it seems weird six moves in but
black is already in trouble
how should we how should we do that
well we can tack a pawn with our pieces
or we can attack it with our pawns
in the way to attack it with our pawns
we have two ways of doing we can play d4
but d4 blocks in our own bishop and
allows him to play e4
so now we should prepare the move f4
which will open our bishop
up and basically tara open up tear open
the position which is good for us
because this queen on e7 is king is
going to be stuck in the center
and the position is generally wide open
so first let's castle so that our rook
is going to be positioned in a way
that will benefit from the file getting
opened
and now let's play
f4 okay
now it doesn't weaken the king um
it does i've talked about this
previously
uh the thing to understand is that not
all king side pawn moves are
the same g4 and h4 are far more
weakening
generally speaking than pushing up the f
pawn because we still have this this
cover he doesn't have any pieces on the
king side
we don't need to worry about this too
much now now we have a great diagonal
but we've got a lot we've got a couple
of things to do here he's probably going
to castle long
and we need to think about how that
impacts our
continued strategy all right
before we think about our strategy
though we need to finish our development
we have a knight on b1 that night is not
developed we need to figure out where we
want to put it
this is where these openings are very
hard to play
for you know for beginners and and for
people who are not too experienced with
chess and
you know not because you're dumb or not
capable of understanding something
because they require
in many cases unconventional developing
moves
because of the demands of the situation
so in this case
if we look at this item where it might
belong e5 seems like a great square
to reach e5 we have to go this way so
the knight has to go to frankfurt
airport
then it has to go toward the center
knight c3 is very awkward
it blocks in the bishop that knight on
c3 doesn't
really have a good roll okay h5
let's get our knight to c4 it looks ugly
but
guess how nice the knight might look
once it reaches e5 we don't have to rush
with knight e5 though
another thing that people can struggle
with
if we're going knight a39 c4 why are we
hesitating about going 95 that's because
the threat is stronger than the
execution
right now he can't cover that square so
perhaps we have more pressing matters
that we want to attend to right now and
then go 95 at some later point
so what should we do well we have a
situation of opposite side castling
and generally speaking in upset side
castling he's already started his attack
we need to start our attack and that's a
pretty tall order because he's got a
very
um very secure pawn bumper on the queen
side but that's not to say we can't
break it down
but we need to start we need to freaking
get on with it so let's
let's go our plan is to go a4 b4 b5
i'll show you guys a classic game uh
where
a pretty weak player makes this happen
and once we do that we want to make this
pawn cover explode he's playing
extremely well by the way folks knight
d5 is really really nice
um so this is this is double-edged
um so let me think for a second
let's move our queen out of the way of
the rook just for the future i don't
want the queen to be x-rayed
let's make sure our queen can come to f2
in case we need to provide more
protection for our own king
now the goal here ultimately is
potentially to prepare before maybe do
some related things
the move c3 would be way too awkward
though it would block in the bishop etc
etc
so is there anything that can be done
well d3 opens up the center i'll talk
about it later
think about what's preventing us from
playing b4 these black pieces here
let's go bishop a3 now yes
that involves bringing the bishop away
from
this diagonal but we have more important
things to do chess is a game where you
have to constantly be shifting your
strategies
based on the demands of the position now
we're going to go rook b1 we're going to
continue preparing before it's not going
to be easy to play this
but we're going to make an attempt h4
now h3 is not dangerous because we could
respond with g3
not too concerned about that um
so let me think very tough opponent
actually this guy
very very tough opponent okay
there's a couple of things that can be
done here i think the time has arrived
now
for us now to play c3 previously our
bishop is on b2
now the urgency of needing to play b4
has superseded
the urgency of looking cool or making
pretty moves we have to play before we
need to open the b
file okay
it's a bit of an odd move but all right
i'm getting up played it's come to my
attention that i'm getting outplayed
here
okay um so let's see let's connect our
rooks
and let's see what happens
g4 let's go 95 to
get rid well try to dislodge his bishop
should back to ca okay
well let's try to expand our empire a
little bit and make some room for the
night
with knight c3 to come
and this is when naredischi was exposed
as the fraud that he is
ladies and gentlemen sorry to say
over red rover
this knight's gonna get trapped with f6
i believe
yeah let's see if he plays f6
or will he start with a percent ultra
precise c5 first perhaps
no f6 immediately oh c5 would have saved
the knight that is true
but i've i've lost hope given how how
skilled this guy is
and now a very complex decision folks
yep which required
precisely three seconds of thinking
yeah again this this always happens in
the speed run thank you gem jam
this these games always happen our
policy is to withhold
our accusations before the game is
checked
with an engine i'm obviously extremely
suspicious i don't usually lose to 1400s
guys
um but we will check the game
to confirm
i'm about 97 confident but there's no
evidence yet
yeah i'm just a little mildly suspicious
rook d3 here this is a model game by
black guys
this is this is how you play dress
actually
g6
let's see what i'm going to do here now
one one pro tip guys
if you're suspicious of somebody and you
want
to generate more evidence try to make
moves
that that like have a human reaction to
them and a computer reaction to them
right um so for example i'm gonna try
i'm gonna try to give you guys an
example
okay let's try queen h5 see
thinking for two seconds
oh now he pre-moves and he pre-moved to
move the first move i think he played on
his own was a mistake but
now well that's not
no that's not the fastest mate actually
this is him just playing
watch him stale maybe okay
i think he's shown up now let me try to
try to save the game
it's pretty close to being stalemate
he can't maybe oh my goodness
oh my lands oh that's hilarious
oh my god lmao
okay so what we do is we load the game
into into chess space now quick
quick pro tip into how i check games you
can use chess.com feature guys
yeah definitely ryan we'll do that and i
promised someone a game
you can use chess.com feature but i use
chess space because
i'll show you guys why this is how
professionals
check games that they're suspicious
about
again and again and again super
important here
to be evidence based
that's one of the components to us
addressing the cheating problem
although of course it it sounds lame
[Music]
one sec please so let's take a look
b3 e5 bishop b2 knight c6
well this was the an attempt to play
this opening
and you can already see queen e7 i'm not
familiar with
actually uh it's it's it's not really a
move that's now the theoretical move is
bishop d6 but it is the top computer
move
interestingly enough uh you guys should
be able to see the text
okay i know it it's out so castles
bishop d7 top i have the top two moves
open just to give us a little bit more
perspective
e4 now f4 was already pretty bad knight
a3 h5
top top
top we give it a second we give it until
like dev25
you know decent bishop a3 is top by the
way
h4 is top top and queenie ate top move
and that's that's
i mean queen e8 queenie a top move
you guys can see i mean it's bla he's
not trying to hide it
bishop c8 he is not trying to hide it
f6 every single move every single one
literally is top stock fish
g62 g62 hilarious
now does this give people joy i just
wonder
and and i want to be i want to be clear
here because i do
do this speed run and people don't know
who i am so i'm not trying to act as if
i'm some sort of saint
uh but with full due respect this is
different so
um i don't know why this gives people
pleasure
no not in the middle of the game in the
end he stopped in the end he stopped
cheating here
right because it was made it literally
was made and made in two
nobody plays this move and then and then
he had made in two again take the knight
which shows me that he knows very little
about chess
rook h1 mate
yeah i don't know if he wanted to troll
me maybe he just played himself
anyways wow what a game what a game
you can say queen eight is the most
insane it doesn't make sense no what it
does
what is why is queenie at the move
because it unpins the what it does is it
unpins the queen
uh and the move b4 is stronger because
there's a pin going on against the queen
um so queenie eight gets the queen to
safety and also it potentially transfers
the queen later when he plays f6
to h5 and f3 potentially yeah why not
queen e6
nobody knows this is insane
well i was suggesting it much earlier
because
and this this boils down to the very
crux it's not about a particular
move some people don't always understand
this
it's it's a general sense i've said this
before
i'll say it again it's a general sense
of being held at arm's length that
you're you're playing these human
ideas and you think you're playing
reasonably
but you're not even in the same
stratosphere
as your opponent is you're not even in
the same mental space
the ideas are on a completely different
level
and nothing phases them yeah
well i'll write his name down because
this is the speedrun account i will
message directly but yeah
okay 20 bucks from gremio love hearing
your videos and learning from the things
richard
you're very welcome my friend
what did gm find we named no never
nobody would ever play queenie magnus
went up like minnie in a blitz game
no impossible totally inhuman
no maybe by coincidence you see if you
give me 10 of these positions i might
play it in one of them
but by and large no
buy and large note
sometimes you can find inhuman moves and
and you need to give allowances for that
there are times when
you know people have found
sequences of crazy moves or ideas in a
fit of inspiration but that's different
from doing it consistently
no it's
it's not about thinking time i don't
think you would play it in classical
it's about the logic of the move being
so
so computerish and concrete that
human logic can't lead you to it
i don't think magnus would play it
what does it accomplish well as i
explained folks it unpins the queen
from the bishop right so b4 was my idea
and it potentially prevents uh or
prepares the queen to swing
to f3 and a lobster instrument later
when he plays f6 and he did that
actually he did it
if you look later in the game his queen
landed on h5 and then it went to f3
so the fact that this occurred a million
moves later is a very computer-ish thing
to see
to sense that this will be good 10 moves
and 10 moves down the line
but let's not focus too much on this one
move there are other moves too bishop c8
here
i mean bishop g4 and then bishop back to
c8 understanding
that this knight on e5 is vulnerable to
the move f6
and it's it's also not about the
strength of the player
these moves are suspicious almost
irrespective of who's playing them
because of the time consumption no human
on magnus not
kasparov hikaru whoever name you know
the chess genius it doesn't matter
it's it's impossible to consume this
amount of time
uh per move and these moves are
inaccessible to human logic for the most
part
[Music]